[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: In this
video, we're going
to walk through how to close
a Cloud billing account using
the console.
Before closing a
billing account,
remember that you'll need
to be a billing account
administrator.
Google Cloud Support cannot
close a billing account
on your behalf.
So reach out to your billing
account admins, if needed.
Get started by heading
to the Cloud Console.
You can start on any
project homepage.
Then head to the Navigation
menu in the left-hand pane.
Choose Billing.
And then click Manage
Billing Accounts.
Select the name of the billing
account you want to close.
This will open the Billing
Accounts Overview page.
In the left-hand nav,
choose Account Management.
Then click on Close
Billing Account
located at the top of the page.
The pop-up dialogue contains
important information
about recommended actions to
take prior to account closing.
Type the word Close and then
click Close Billing Account.
The billing account
is now closed,
and it's indicated by the red
banner at the top of the page.
Closing the billing account
stops all billable services
and any projects
linked to the account,
preventing the account from
accruing further charges.
Final charges for the
account will be fully accrued
48 hours after the
closure and will
be reflected on your final bill
based on your current billing
cycle.
This bill will be the
last bill you receive
unless you reopen the account.
Head over to the documentation
to check out more details.
[MUSIC PLAYING]